Multicellular organisms begin life as a
small bundle of cells that are all
fairly similar to one another. So how
do they get from that little bundle of
cells to a fully functional organism
that has many different kinds of cells
that perform vastly different functions?
It's through a process called cellular
differentiation. It's similar to what
the name sounds like— the process of
making cells different from one another.
Most of the cells in that little bundle
at the beginning of life are
pluripotent. They have the potential to
become many different things. These are
called stem cells, and eventually they
can become brain cells, bone cells,
blood cells and many more. Through the
process of development, cells receive
signals that instruct them to become
different cell types that serve
specific functions. Once cells
differentiate into a new cell type,
they retain their new identity
permanently.
They can divide into more of the same
type of cell or differentiate into
another specialized cell type, but they
do not usually revert back to their
beginning stem cell state. There are
ways that we can use to turn
differentiated cells back into stem
cells. If you want to learn more, check
out the iPSC video. In addition,
differentiation does not just occur
during development of an organism. Most
adult organisms have stem cells in
their bodies that will differentiate
into specific cell types as needed. One
example are the stem cells located in
your bone marrow. These differentiate
into multiple different types of blood
cells depending on what is needed. So
the next time you see someone who
donated blood, thank them for their
generosity and thank the process of
differentiation that allows their stem
cells to replace the blood cells that
they lost.